there's some people were like genuinely
scary movies around Halloween you know
what I like
Sherlock so I said I might make this as
an occasional series and yeah I think I
am in fact gonna do that silver linings
where I talk about a movie that I know
is not good but still has things about
it that I love unabashedly and being
October and as we are closing into
Halloween I thought it would be a fun
time to talk about a horror movie a
ghost movie that is not good but I
really enjoy it and I can tell you
precisely why the house on Haunted Hill
now this is a remake of of a
quote-unquote classic horror film and it
is decent it's not great
it's pretty it's pretty bog-standard
bunch of people go to this building that
is haunted has a terrible history used
to be an asylum and there was a doctor
who did experiments on the inmates
pretty wrote stuff they all get stuck
inside and the malevolent force that
lives in there begins to pick them off
it's very run-of-the-mill it could very
easily have been made for TV it could
very easily have been direct-to-dvd it
did actually get a theatrical release
but I love this film and I love this
film for two reasons
Geoffrey Rush and fomka Johnson these
two who the rest of the cast actually
isn't bad either
but these two specifically they play the
prices
it's hard to say if I wanted to say that
they're the main characters I think they
were the biggest names at the time the
movie came out but so the deal is Falcon
Johnson's character her birthday is
coming and she wants something
ridiculous and over-the-top and spooky
from her incredibly rich husband which
she is in a god I think calling it a
loveless marriage would be generous and
that character is played by Geoffrey
Rush so Falcon Jensen just wants
absurdity and a lot of money spent and
expects him to do that and he his idea
is fine you want this you want it at
this crazy haunted place fine I'll rent
it out oh I'm gonna swap out your guest
list though for all these other people
although the apparent apparently big
ghost king can communicate over the
internet go into his email list and
change the the guest list something else
again it's not a good movie it's dumb so
we end up with all these people at this
place you don't know each other have no
reason to trust each other but the
dynamic and the scenes and the just
gleeful hatred the Geoffrey Rush and
famke janssen have for each other
it is amazing their scenes together are
some of my favorite things on film
honestly because these are two people
the the implication is she married him
for his money he married her to cover up
the fact that he was gay and might favor
men significantly younger than himself
which I didn't really watch it before
talking about this I don't know if they
mention how young he tends to favor that
might actually be way more uncomfortable
than it used to be
I should have checked that now I'm gonna
be scared too in any case he you know
he's she is his beard he is her sugar
daddy
but they don't love each other not
really never did that's the implication
at least and there are scenes that the
two of these that these two people have
together I think my favorite moment that
I think sums it up perfectly is they're
getting into an argument and Geoffrey
Rush kind of puts his hand on the back
of her head and grabs her hair a little
bit
he's not like yanking her around he's
just kinda like mm-hmm
Oh with aggravation she goes you're
hurting me and he's like I know
and then she scratches and bites and
bites him and he's like oh well there's
the fine country girl I'm married that
is the relationship between these two
and I doesn't seem that I just cited
makes it seems like he is physically
abusing her he's it's it's really just
applied that each one of them would
really like the other one to die they
might not be at the point yet where
they're ready to actively try and kill
the other one but they really it would
be great if the other one would die like
one of my other favorite moments I love
this line from [ __ ] Jensen she
delivers it so well if you really loved
me you'd find a way to drop dead in the
next five seconds oh oh no I don't know
what I want to do with that line but I
want it I want that line in my life I
love it so much and unfortunately I wish
the entire movie was them it was like it
was like War of the Roses in a haunted
house I wish that was the whole movie
but there are other people generic
ghosts and stuff
Taye Diggs is there you know it's it's
an odd kind of cast and it's fine Peter
Gallagher's in it
it's fine and it gets the job done it's
competent as far as everything else goes
but really it's those two that make this
a movie that I enjoy watching and
actually funnily enough I feel like the
spirit of those characters I feel like
that is a big part of what I like about
American horror
story is that sort of high camp in a
horror setting is kind of what American
Horror Story does and I I'm not I'm not
certainly not proposing that American
Horror Story was directly taking
influence from this movie I seriously
doubt it but I feel like they they the
things at least that I like best about
both both those things are playing from
a similar vibe and it's one I can't get
in too many other places and I really do
enjoy so if you've never seen this movie
again I'm not promising you a good movie
but I am promising you a fun time in
something terrific interactions and the
just the most fun viciousness between a
married couple that you can find on film
so if you haven't seen this movie before
go ahead check it out I think you'll at
least have fun I mean like worst-case
scenario take enjoyment for that part as
I do
you could easily miss your Science
Theater 3000 in this movie with some
friends and still have a good time so
that's it I don't know consider that out
of nowhere this has become a bit of a
Halloween recommendation again for fun
not for quality in but we'll wrap it up
there so that my friends those two they
are the silver lining to another wise
weird movie where Chris Kattan tries to
deliver dialog about why they're all
gonna die in a house and oddly enough I
kind of liked that too but I can't
expect one I can't even explain but yeah
silver lining to another wise
Fairley wrote ghost movie so those are
my thoughts on the house on Haunted Hill
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff you can do there's links and
there's buttons including a link to my
patreon check them out if you feel like
it if you don't hey don't worry about it
because you know what you're the council
and I only run the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]